As I've mentioned to you before each of the
3 aspects of experience so the things you
know the things you don’t know and the fact
of yourself have a very ambivalent underlying
structure both positive and negative so that
the things you don’t know are interesting
and compelling in the sources of new information
but also the source of the things that undermine
you both physically and mentally
And the things you know of course your culture
disciplines you and shapes you into a full
person but also at exactly the same time molds
you and crushes you in a particular direction
rather than any of the directions you might
have gone in
And then finally with regards to the individual
we spent a substantial amount of time discussing
the individual’s capability capacity to
make order out of chaos and sometimes to make
chaos out of order in the service of a higher
order
And that’s all to the good but just like
culture and nature have their negative aspects
so do the individual
And I think personally this is where Christian
mythology in particular comes into its own
I think of all the major religions Christianity
has the most thoroughly developed what you
might describe as formal model of evil and
that model isn't part of the canonical writings
of Christianity say encapsulated in the Bible
but part of cloud of sort of natural mythology
and storytelling that surrounds the canonical
writings
so you could say that although Christainity
and Buddhism have spent a substantial amount
of time developing up a representation of
the hero Christianity in particular has also
spent a substantial amount of time developing
a formal portrait of the figure that stands
in opposition to the hero
and I think the most appropriate term for
that figure who takes multiple forms in mythology
is the adversary because the adversarial spirit
is a spirit that stands in opposition to everything
Stands in opposition to nature stands in opposition
to culture and most specifically stands in
opposition to that aspect of the human being
that’s both exploratory and creative
Now the last time we talked I had a chance
to describe to you how the figures of the
adversarial brothers emerged naturally at
the end of genesis as a coda to the story
right Adam and Eve develop self consciousness
they develop knowledge of their own mortality
and death and as the primordial parents of
humanity their first children take the form
of the hostile brothers which is to say that
if you're the child of nature the child of
culture this sort of ultimate parents then
as an individual you take two forms a positive
form and a negative form
and the negative form is characterized in
many ways by the kind of absolute hatred of
the good hatred of the positive form and I
think that you can’t understand the full
human propensity for evil without considering
more than the territoriality more than the
innate territoriality of human being
so if you look at animals well animals are
territorial and they fight to preserve their
territory and it’s a rational struggle they're
fighting for resources and for a place that
they can that they can operate and live in
and reproduce in efficiently
but human beings are substantively different
from that in that their agonistic conflict
their aggression often seems to be motivated
by something more akin to the pure desire
for destruction rather than for any rational
end whatsoever
And so from that perspective I would say as
an example the fact that Hitler ended up committing
suicide in a bunker beneath Germany’s capital
at the end of the second world war when Berlin
was in flames when all of Germany was in flames
and when his country was completely defeated
after tens of millions of people had died
in the conflict including of course the 7
million or so people that were killed in the
Holocaust.
the normal mode of interpretation of that
would be what a terrible defeat for Hitler
but an equally valid and I think um an equally
valid prima facie argument and one I think
that’s actually more valid is that wasn’t
a defeat for Hitler at all it was precisely
what he was aiming at right from the beginning
because his mode of being was intensely adversarial
And I would also say that it’s certainly
possible that the full nature of these motivations
weren't even necessarily clear to him As they
unfolded across time during the second world
war no more than the full motivations of any
human being are necessarily accessible to
them as they act out whatever it is that they
act out
so Carl Jung says for example that we act
out great mythological stories that doesn’t
necessarily mean you know the story just means
you act it out
so for example you see people whose lives
are repetitive bouts of tragedy and what they're
acting out is a tragic story and they know
it insofar as they're actually acting it out
but they don’t necessarily have an explicit
model of the relationship between their patterns
of behaviour and the constantly tragic outcome
they produce
Well that doesn’t even necessarily mean
that what they're doing isn't voluntary Because
things can be voluntary even if you don’t
understand them fully
There's an aspect to the human psyche that’s
a “nest of vipers” so to speak because
you can’t necessarily trust what you see
and that means not only when you're looking
at someone else say but even when you're looking
in the mirror you can’t be sure that what
you say you're doing is exactly what you're
doing.
Your motivations aren't transparent and they
may not even be clear
so I suppose the idea that lurks behind this
formalization is that freedom of choice is
such a good that one of its subsidiary necessities
which is that there has to be a polar distinction
between good and evil is worth having freedom
is so important that it justifies the distinction
between good and evil
and I think that art I think that’s a reasonable
way to presume It’s reasonable to presume
that that’s the manner in which experience
is actually structured and there's complex
reasons for that
one would be that under the most optimal circumstances
which is something we’ll talk about as this
proceeds to a close that means in a sense
you can have your cake and eat it too
Which means the potential existence of good
and evil allows for freedom of choice And
then if the choice is always towards the good
then you have the benefits of freedom of choice
plus the benefits of the good the only price
you have to pay is the constant possibility
of evil.
It’s very much like the structure of Christianity
so you have the highest god who’s whose
highest son is Christ but you have the figure
of the Satan lurking in the background who’s
also got a filial relationship with the highest
god.
and it makes for a confusing kind of theology
because in many situations of course Christ
is identified specifically with God the father
but Satan always lurks in the background and
his existential status is indeterminate because
since God is everything then it’s very difficult
to make the case that the evil spirit isn't
a derivative of God it’s not easy thing
to get straightened out rationally
and I think Milton in Paradise Lost has a
very good attempt good attempt to explain
exactly what this might mean how there could
be an overarching transcendent power And there
could be two subordinate elements to that
one evil and one good without destroying the
idea that God as such is good and without
eradicating the reality of evil a very very
complex argument to make
Now the notion of evil is also very very complex
idea so if you look at arguments that support
Atheism and I've mentioned some of these like
Ivan’s argument and the Brothers Karamazov
where Ivan says well the world as such experience
as such must be evil because it’s predicated
on the blood of innocence the suffering of
children the fact that there's vast injustices
in the world is indicative that there's no
such thing as a good god or to speak in personified
terms is evidence that the structure of experience
as such is untenable morally it shouldn’t
be.
Because it’s predicated on suffering
Jeffrey Burton Russell who’s written whole
series of books on the nature of evil makes
a very clear distinction between different
categories of terrible events that I think
help bring this into clarity so imagine this
imagine first that it’s useful to make a
distinction between tragedy and evil.
Okay now tragedy is when the bad befalls the
good an earthquake is tragic or disease is
tragic.
now it’s easy to regard a disease or an
earthquake as evil as well but the problem
with that is there doesn’t seem to be any
motivation to it
And so it’s more likely it’s more reasonable
to think something like well people are vulnerable
and have to be vulnerable in order to give
existence a viewpoint one of the consequences
of their vulnerability is that they're susceptible
to tragedy
Okay If their vulnerability is a precondition
for being then the fact that they're susceptible
to tragedy isn't necessarily an evil it’s
just a consequence of their limitation.
Then you say well what constitutes evil if
you can’t put earthquakes and diseases and
so forth into that category.
Well then it seems to be something more dependent
on choice which is the argument that Eliade
is making
Say the world does all sorts of terrible things
to people but there are frequent - it’s
frequently the case that people act in such
a way that make things worse rather than better.
right so if you look at the consequences of
the rise to power of the Nazis for example
doesn’t seem reasonable to put the Nazi
concentration camp in the same category from
an ethical perspective as the earthquake
Because the earthquake is an emergent consequence
of the rules that govern physical existence.
Whereas the Nazi death camp is something that
was planned it didn't have to be it seems
to be an aspect of choice.
And this seems to be the idea that’s lurking
underneath both this mythology and Eliade’s
comment on it it’s the mere fact that the
world is terrible does not mean that it’s
evil
but then when you look at specifically human
actions there's this aspect of twisted choice
that Frye also makes much of
He says if you look at the structure of human
history and you try to explain why it has
such a bloody and terrible course it doesn’t
seem sufficient just to attribute it say to
the conditions of existence or to ignorance
it seems more like there's a force behind
it so to speak manifest say in every individual.
But actually aiming at the suffering instead
of just allowing it to happen or instead of
not stepping in to stop it but actually aiming
at it
Now so let’s take a look at the stories.
And let’s take a look at the leading figures
so we know for example that the figure of
Satan in Christianity is associated with a
number of strange forms
right the first association we know if is
that he’s associated with the… with the
dragon and in the garden of Eden
right so there's and so that there's a profound
ambivalence in Christianity about the meaning
of the opening act of Genesis
because on the one hand you have when Adam
and Eve are still profoundly unconscious they
don’t suffer But they're profoundly unconscious
right they're not self conscious they're not
aware of themselves so in many ways they're
still animals
So there's a Gnostic line of speculation.
The Gnostics were a Christian sect that believed
that redemption could at least partly be attained
by understanding rather than just faith
The Gnostics believed that the serpent that
tempted Adam and Eve towards self consciousness
was a more developed aspect of God than the
God that had created Adam and Eve to begin
with because the unconsciousness that characterized
Adam and Eve was too underdeveloped to be
perfect and so they had to be tempted forward
into a more fully developed consciousness.
and so although classical Christianity associated
the serpent in the tree with Lucifer who’s
the bringer of light who’s Satan the Gnostic
thread of reasoning said well wait a minute
it’s not that simple
because yeah self-consciousness makes you
aware of death and vulnerability and knocks
you out into the profane world but there's
an aspect of it that looks like enlightenment
- and you know this already in your own lives
because often when you believe something and
you're unconsciously convinced of the adequacy
of that model and then you find that it’s
not sufficient right and so you crumble in
disappointment
you put your trust in someone and you find
out say they're not worthy of that trust and
that the evidence that enlightens you breaks
that frame of reference and makes you collapse
you think that’s a terrible thing you can’t
help but feel that as a real betrayal and
as an act even of evil but then a year later
two years later you might look back and God
you know I really needed that I really needed
that lesson because as a consequence of learning
that I'm much more mature and much more likely
to establish stable relationships
and so it’s easy to see that from one perspective
something can be terrible then from another
it might not be terrible at all
and even in classic Christianity you get this
strange ambivalence about the events in Genesis
that runs something like this
Well yes it was an act of the most evil spirit
the spirit of enlightenment the spirit of
rationality the bringer of light Lucifer to
knock Adam and Eve out of their transcendental
unconsciousness and to start history it was
an evil act but on the other hand it was also
the pre-condition for the later emergence
of Christ and as far as the Christians are
concerned that’s the greatest event in history
so without this initial opening act this tragic
opening act there’d be no reason the whole
redemptive story and therefore considered
from the perspective of the total story the
opening tragedy cannot purely be considered
evil
Very very complicated line of reasoning
Now the other thing you see here and I think
this relates back to our initial map is and
this also helps you understand the way people
think now I said all ready that it’s really
easy to confuse tragedy and evil right
okay so what that means is that it’s real
easy to confuse the negative aspect of the
unknown with evil
And likewise it’s very easy to confuse the
negative aspect of culture with evil your
own culture the tyrannical aspect of it or
the culture of other people
So it’s very easy, for example, for us to
demonize the foreigner and that’s basically
because there's a part of our mind that presumes
that all things that strike us negatively
all things that produce negative emotion on
our part like fear are the same thing
So there's a blurry category of evil that’s
all terrible natural things all terrible social
things and then whatever nastiness the individual
can generate among themselves It’s much
more useful to draw a clear distinction between
these different categories.
beause that clarity of thought can help you
focus in most specifically on those things
that the individual is responsible for in
terms of turning the world to waste
so milton says this figure of satan lucifer
the light bringer always associated with rationality
Milton presents him as a remarkable creature
right he’s the highest angel in God’s
heavenly hierarchy he’s Christ’s brother
in a similar mythological vein he’s the
most powerful angel that ever lived.
So at least in the opening stages of this
act Satan is presented as something absolutely
remarkable
Now the problem is here his very remarkableness
starts to work against him
And what happens is that as he grows in power
and strength in this heavenly hierarchy he
starts to become convinced that that omniscient
himself whatever that transcendent figure
is is unnecessary so the idea is that whatever
Satan represents decides because of his own
pride his own belief in his own sufficiency
that the transcendent can be eradicated from
consideration and the way Milton presents
that as a revolution in heaven fundamentally.
So imagine that the story is something like
this.
Well, George Kelly way back in like 1955 noted
that what human beings like more than anything
else really when they get right down to it
is to be right
Why?
Well it’s a pain to be wrong right because
if you're wrong then whatever structure that
you're using to conjure up the world has to
dissolve but then you have to do a lot of
really aggravating work exploratory work and
creative work to put it back together
And during the time before you put it back
together then you're flooded with negative
motivational states right you don’t know
which way is up Metaphorically speaking
So we don’t like to be you don’t like
not to be right and so what does that mean
Well psychologists know that people have a
very strong confirmatory bias which basically
means that if you bring a frame of reference
to bear on the world the probability is very
high that you will look for confirming evidence
and you discount disconfirming evidence
Now the other thing that is characteristic
of great figures of evil like Satan is the
tendency to lie so Satan is prince of lie
now what does that mean exactly?
So, TS Eliot wrote this poem called the Cocktail
Hour he talks about this woman who goes into
a psychiatric treatment the woman says to
the psychiatrist I'm telling you I really
really hope there's something wrong with me
Because I'm having a miserable time of it
And as far as I can tell there's only two
options here.
Either I'm okay and I'm having a miserable
time because the world is terrible which case
nothing I can do about it or there's something
wrong with me at some level of analysis that
I don’t really comprehend and although that’s
a painful option I'm really hoping it’s
true because if there's something wrong with
me possibly I can fix it and if there's something
wrong with the structure of the world well
what's there to do about that
Often what you see in psychotherapy is a battle
between those two perspectives going on in
the minds of the client that the client is
in a situation where they're repetetively
facing tragedy.
they have a specific viewpoint about the world
but the viewpoint might be well when it comes
right down to it you really can’t trust
other people And they have all sorts of reasons
for believing that they abused his children
or they had a bad developmental history a
number of relationships that hadn't gone well
they have all the facts at their disposal
to justify that particular perspective
but the truth of the matter is that as long
as they hold onto that belief and won’t
let it go and no wonder they won’t they're
gonna continue to suffer
and part of what you always do to someone
in therapy saying you know yeah you got a
pretty coherent view of the world and all
that and I can understand why you'd like to
cram the whole world into that coherent perspective
but the truth of the matter is as long as
you hold onto that and won’t sacrifice it
won’t go through this terrible period of
dissolution it’s always gonna produce this
same tragic consequences
so as long as you hold onto your belief rigidly
everything around you is gonna go from bad
to worse.
Northrop Frye says with regards to such states
that “a demonic fall as Milton presents
it involves defiance of and rivalry with God
rather than simple disobedience and hence
the demonic society is a sustained and systematic
parody of the divine one associated with devils
or fallen angels because it seems far beyond
normal human capacities in its powers We read
of ascending and descending angels on Jacob’s
and Plato’s ladders and similarly there
seem to be demonic reinforcements in heathen
life that account for the almost superhuman
grandeur of the heathen empires especially
just before they fall Two particularly notable
passages in the Old Testament prophets linked
to this theme are the denunciation of Babylon
in Isaiah 14 and of Tyre in Ezekiel 28 Babylon
is associated with Lucifer the morning star
who said to himself ‘I will be like the
Most High’.
okay so let’s translate that into modern
language and forget about Babylon let’s
take a Soviet Union for example Instead and
let’s say something like this
"I will be like the most high" well first
of all it’s not difficult to read Stalin
into that from a personal perspective but
then it’s more complicated than that because
you can’t blame the Soviet Union on Stalin
When the wall fell down we know that one third
of east Germans were KGB informers you can’t
blame that on Stalin you have to blame that
on the one third of the east Germans who were
KGB informers right
it’s this totalitarian presupposition presumption
is distributed through the whole society
there's a leader and a hierarchy and all that
but they’re not the people to be identified
with the fact of the totalitarian state
It’s distributed through the whole society
and it’s precisely this it’s what I don’t
know I don’t need I don’t need what I
don't know
one of the things I really liked about this
sort of Christian metaphysical take on the
problem of evil is that it… it adopts strange
first principles
like if you're an empirical scientist it’s
very difficult to come to terms with the notion
of free choice
Right because there are no deterministic models
of free choice we don’t know how that might
occur although.
if it seems to be a reasonable phenomenological
observation that if there's anything true
about existence about the facts of existence
as it’s subjectively construed the fact
that you seem to have the faculty of choice
seems paramount or primary now…
one might say well that’s just a delusion
and we know that because our deterministic
models have been so powerful
Or one might say well alternatively we’re
going to presume the subjective experience
to be true and saying well our deterministic
models just aren't sophisticated enough and
there's no real reason to choose between either
of those on a name a priori basis right they're
perhaps equally plausible
And we also might note the deterministic perspective
of course that if you go down far enough in
your analysis of physical structures down
to the quantum level say then deterministic
models don’t hold at all
So determinism have its limits at the lower
end or higher resolution end of physical inquiry
I have no idea what that might mean for free
choice
It just means that our level of analysis that
deterministic models do not describe
Christianity takes the stance that the subjective
the subjective sense of freedom is accurate
And then tries to build the world from that
point It presumes that’s in axiomatic principle
and so you have God in Milton’s Paradise
Lost saying with regards both to Lucifer and
to human beings who are fallen he says "some
will fall he and his faithless progeny speaking
of human beings whose fault whose but his
own ingrate he had of me all he could've I
made him just and right sufficient to have
stood though free to fall "
I like that I think that makes a fair bit
of sense to me
I started to understand this most particularly
as a consequence of reading Carl Jung because
Jung has this really interesting notion and
I think it’s tied to the idea in Genesis
that as soon as Adam becomes self conscious
he hides from God
So what if it was this and you can take an
evolutionary tack on this too What if it was
this what if it was the case that if you never
turned away from any phenomenological evidence
then you build a personality that would be
strong enough to withstand tragedy
What if that was the case So the idea here
being let’s say you are the person who notes
that his or her friends don’t exactly trust
me, What do you do?
Well to hide away you just walk away and then
of course you never learn anything
But let’s say by contrast you say well no
the first time you get any evidence that you're
not 100% trusted you say look I got this pang
in my heart saying the communication between
you and I is not exactly straight
Now something’s going on here either you
haven't got your frame of reference with regards
to me right or there's something wrong with
the way I'm looking at the world Those are
the options so let’s have it out
You got this attitude and it’s doing it’s
hurting me Tell me what you have to say and
I’ll tell you what I have to say and we’ll
exchange this pattern of information and as
a consequence we’re both gonna walk away
a little bit more well put together
God says yeah yeah people get disturbed and
twisted and bent and warped but that’s their
own problem fundamentally because they have
this capacity just to turn away.
And as they turn away they get weaker and
as they get weaker the world gets worse around
them because they can’t deal with it and
they keep making mistakes and that’s a terrible
consequence and all that but if they just
wouldn’t turn away to begin with then there'd
be no problem
And there wouldn’t be no problem because
the world would stop being tragic because
the world’s tragic right I mean there you
are little and vulnerable and you know things
can roll right over you the world can demolish
you but the idea would be instead that you
could handle it without becoming corrupted
and that would be sufficient
so the idea would be it’s a tough situation
all things considered but it’s also an interesting
and compelling and beautiful one and it maybe
that if you didn't turn away the interesting
and beautiful and compelling aspect would
overwhelm the tragic aspect and that would
be fine.